hey everyone welcome to another
installment of Harry Potter Theory today
we're going to be discussing abandoned
plot lines in the Harry Potter series
when we reminisce about JK Rowling and
her incredible world it's hard not to
think about all the tweaks and twists
she's made to Harry Potter Canon over
the years from publishings on Pottermore
Wizarding World to the Fantastic Beasts
movies all the way to her active
presence on Twitter Rowling seems to
have an unending desire to shake things
up but amidst all these additions and
alterations there have also been
mentions of things that Roland
considered but later chose to discard
from relatively minor to Major today
we'll be discussing the changes to the
story that didn't make the cut discarded
Treasures that were banished to the
literary bin after the video let me know
what you think should have slash should
not have been included down in the
comment section below anyway let's get
into it
1. Ron Weasley bullmast dying in the
middle of the series
kicking things off for the big one the
death of Ron in the very early stages of
JK Rowling's creative process there were
originally some discussions about the
possibility of Ron Weasley dying
this Prospect came from JK Rowling's
eagerness to delve into darker themes
and potentially offer a more dramatic
and devastating twist to the narrative
and devastating it would have been as
the loss of Ron would undoubtedly have
caused profound grief not only to Harry
and Hermione but to fans worldwide
it also would have had some serious
ramifications Ron's absence would have
completely altered the Dynamics of the
trio leaving Harry and Hermione to
navigate their Journeys without their
loyal companion furthermore the loss of
Ron's humor warmth and unwavering
loyalty would have undoubtedly left a
palpable void in the series changing the
course of events in the relationship
between the characters however
fortunately for us as the series
progressed Rowling recognized the vital
role Ron played within the story his
humor bravery and unwavering support
provided a much-needed balance to the
darker elements of The Wizarding World
ultimately she made the decision to
spare Ron's life allowing him to
continue growing alongside Harry
Hermione and contributing to the
ultimate defeat of Voldemort
funnily enough I planned from the start
that none of the trio would die then
Midway through which I think is a
reflection of the fact that I wasn't in
a very happy place I started thinking I
might polish one of them off out of
sheer spite there now you definitely
can't have him anymore but I think in my
absolute heart of hearts although I did
seriously consider killing Ron I
wouldn't have done it 2. Arthur Weasley
dying as if killing Fred and nearly Ron
wasn't enough it turns out that Rowling
had also considered killing off the
patriarch of the Weasley Clan Arthur JK
Rowling has been quite vocal in
interviews about her impulses to kill
parents in order to amplify the fear
Lord Voldemort brought upon the
Wizarding World in the fifth installment
of the Harry Potter series order of the
Phoenix Arthur Weasley became the target
of that impulse in this book Arthur
experiences a harrowing and nearly fatal
assault by nagini Lord Voldemort's
Serpentine companion inside of the
Department of mysteries but fortunately
Rowling couldn't bear to lose Arthur if
there's one character I couldn't bear to
part with it's Arthur Weasley she told
the Today Show back in 2007 I think part
of the reason for that is that there
were very few good Fathers in the book
in fact it could make a very good case
for Arthur Weasley being the only good
father in the whole series fortunately
Arthur ultimately recovered at Saint
mungo's Hospital although it's worth
noting that a few muggle stitches made
no difference in his miraculous healing
his survival was significant in
maintaining the theme of Hope and family
within the story Rowling felt that
killing Arthur would have been too
tragic and would have had too much of a
negative impact on the overall tone of
the story moving forward
3. Hermione's dance saving Harry instead
of Hagrid although Hermione's parents
being Muggles LED separate lives from
Hermione and are not extensively
featured in the books it turns out there
was originally a possibility for
Hermione's father to have a more
significant role in The Narrative during
Rowling's planning phase for the
Philosopher's Stone she considered a
storyline where the Granger and Potter
families were acquainted in this
alternate scenario The Potter's resided
on an island while the Grangers lived on
the mainland when an explosion occurred
in The Potter's location the Grangers
would have rushed to their aid
originally it was Hermione's father who
was envisioned as the one who'd rescued
Harry and brought him to the dursleys
however Rowling ultimately assigned this
pivotal role to Hagrid the very very
earliest drafts of the first chapter of
Philosopher's Stone have the Potters
living on a remote island Hermione's
family living on the mainland her father
spotting something that resembles an
explosion out at Sea and sailing out in
a storm to find their bodies in the
ruins of their house I can't remember
now why I thought this was a good idea
but I clearly recognize that it wasn't
fairly early on because the Potters were
relocated to godrick's hollow for all
subsequent drafts it certainly would
have been interesting for the Granger
Clan to have had more significant
contributions to the story particularly
as they would have enlightened us with a
muggle perspective on The Wizarding
World that was a little more pro-magic
before theodorant being a rival bully to
Draco Malfoy Theodore not Slytherin
student did make it into the Harry
Potter books however his role did change
quite substantially as it turns out knot
was originally conceived as a potential
rival to Draco Malfoy however this
plotline was ultimately abandoned likely
to allow Draco to remain the main
antagonist from Sutherland and maintain
consistency with his character
development evidently Theodore did not
remain a bully essentially the two would
have acted as Southern Rivals with not
being the more clever of the two boys we
rarely see Draco talking to anybody he
considers a real equal and he is forced
to see Theodore as such because Theodore
is just as pure-blooded as he is and
somewhat cleverer Rowling said
together these two death eater's Sons
discussed Dumbledore's regime at
Hogwarts and Harry Potter with all sorts
of stories that the Death Eaters tell
about how this baby boy survived the
Dark Lord's attack during the creation
of the Harry Potter series JK Rowling
even developed a subplot for the pair in
the subplot Theodore knot and Draco
Malfoy were depicted engaging in
conversation in the garden of Malfoy
Manor so fond was rolling of this scene
that she attempted to incorporate it
twice in the series firstly in Harry
Potter and the Chamber of Secrets and
then again in Harry Potter and the
Goblet of Fire however this particular
subplot did not make its way into the
published books 5. Hermione's sister in
the early stages of writing JK Rowling
considered giving Hermione a younger
sister a character that we only know as
Miss Granger however this plotline was
abandoned and Hermione remained an only
child throughout the series the reasons
for this change are not explicitly
stated but it is possible rolling felt
the introduction of a sibling could
unnecessarily complicate Hermione's
character Arc and the Dynamics within
the trio
I always planted Hermione would have a
youngest sister but she's never made an
appearance and somehow it feels like it
might be too late now Hermione's younger
sister was apparently due to arrive at
Hogwarts sometime around the fourth book
Harry Potter and the Goblet of Fire but
by the time the fifth book Harry Potter
and the Order of the Phoenix was
released Rowling believed it was too
late I do Wonder though if Hermione and
her sister would have recreated the
plight of Lily and petunia Evans
6. The Last Words as many of you will
already know the closing words of the
Harry Potter books were all was well a
statement that has satisfied some and
caused Fury in others though relevant
I've always felt as though this rather
basic collection of words left a lot to
be desired in an otherwise superb
collection of books however it turns out
that JK Rowling once considered closing
out the books with something else
initially JK Rowling considered closing
out the series with the word scar
instead of all was well the word scar of
course holds great symbolism throughout
the Harry Potter series as the
lightning-shaped scar on Harry Potter's
forehead serves as a constant reminder
of his connection to the Dark Lord
Voldemort and the traumatic events he's
experienced choosing to end the series
with the word scar would have emphasized
the lingering effects of Harry's past
and the lasting presence of darkness in
The Wizarding World by opting for all
was well instead JK Rowling conveyed a
different tone and message the phrase
implies a sense of resolution indicating
that the struggles and conflicts of the
story have been overcome and a state of
peace and Harmony has been achieved it
provides closure for readers by
reassuring them that the characters they
have grown to love are living in a world
where they can finally find Solace
unfortunately we don't have any more
info about the potential build up to the
word SCAR or what that would have looked
like 7. Dudley dursley's wizard son in
an interview JK Rowling once mentioned
that she contemplated giving Dudley
dursley Harry's awful cousin a son that
would turn out to be a wizard throughout
the first books bloody displays spoiled
self-centered and cruel Behavior he
along with his parents treat Harry with
disdain and Bully him excessively
however as the series progresses there
is a gradual shift in Dudley's attitude
towards Harry culminating in a deleted
scene where he finally extends an olive
branch in this moment of redemption
Dudley extends his hand to Harry and
finally acknowledges his worth carefully
admitting I don't think you're a waste
of space and that was the first time we
really saw the good side of Dudley
dursley evidently Rowling had initially
planned to take this Dudley Redemption
Arc even further by giving him a magical
child of his own in this alternate
subplots Dudley's magical son would have
been seen in the epilogue along with
Harry's at King's cross station being
sent off on his own magical journey to
Hogwarts however this idea was later
scrapped as Rowling refused to believe
that any Wizarding genes could survive
being mixed with Vernon's DNA
by giving Dudley a magical child Rawling
would have offered an opportunity for
Dudley to confront and challenge his
negative beliefs and biases Against The
Wizarding World after the books ended
Rowling did eventually reveal that
Dudley went on to have a family of his
own raising two Michael children
Harry and Dudley would still see each
other enough to be on Christmas card
terms but they would visit more out of a
sense of Duty and sit in silence that
their children could see their cousins
eight the Sorting Hat the Sorting Hat a
legendary artifact of Hogwarts created
by the four Founders holds the power to
determine which house a new student
belongs to it scans the thoughts traits
and talents of the wearer delving into
their very essence with this Insight the
Sorting Hat uses its wisdom to assign
the student to Gryffindor Hufflepuff
Ravenclaw also the redneck the four
houses of Hogwarts represent a tapestry
of diverse virtues nurturing distinct
qualities within their members and in
many ways the Sorting Hat has
transcended the page with nearly every
die-hard Harry Potter fan proudly
professing their Hogwarts house to
anyone who will listen
but what if I told you that the Sorting
hats nearly didn't exist though Rowling
was sure that she wanted students sorted
into four different houses with their
own unique qualities the Sorting Hat at
a couple lack cluster early incantations
originally Rowling wanted the Sorting
Hat to be a machine that did all kinds
of magical things before reaching a
decision Rowling herself admitted that
this idea was too easy next she toyed
with the idea of students being sorted
by the ghosts of the four Founders the
ghosts would exist inside statues that
came alive in the entrance hall picking
children for their houses one by one
following dance rolling grappled with a
few more basic ideas including drawing
straws being picked by team captain and
pulling names from a hat the final idea
is what's stuck but instead of putting
names in a hat the Hat itself ended up
with the responsibility of choosing the
student's fate 9. Florian Fortescue the
Florian Fortescue we know was the owner
of Florian 40 skew's ice cream parlor
located in Diagon Alley although his
character did not play a significant
role in the books he did interact with
Harry in Prisoner of Azkaban where he
revealed his extensive knowledge about
medieval Wizards unfortunately in the
summer of 1996 Fortescue was abducted
and later murdered by Lord Voldemort
because Fortescue plays such a minor
role he's not particularly memorable or
useful but as it turns out he was the
subject of a ghost plot that never made
it into the final Story one which would
have placed great importance on his
character Florian Fortescue owner of an
ice cream parlor in Diagon Alley is the
subject of a ghost plot a narrative that
never made it into the final books Harry
meets him in Prisoner of Azkaban later
Harry discovers that an ex Headmaster of
Hogwarts was called Dexter Fortescue
Florian is a descendant of Dexter and I
originally planned Florian to be the
conduit for clues that I needed to give
Harry during his quest for the Hallows
which is why I established an
acquaintance fairly early on at this
stage I imagined the historically minded
Florian might have a smattering of
information on matters as diverse as the
Elder Wand and the diadem of Ravenclaw
the information having been passed down
in the Fortescue family from their
ancient ancestor as I worked my way
nearer to the point where such
information would become necessary I
caused Florian to be kidnapped intending
him to be found or rescued by Harry and
his friends the problem was that when I
came to write the key parts of Deathly
Hallows I decided that Phineas nigellus
black was a much more satisfactory means
of conveying Clues Florian's information
on the diadem also felt redundant as I
could give the reader everything he or
she needed by interviewing the gray lady
all in all assumed to have had him
kidnapped and came killed for no reason
he is not the first wizard whom
Voldemort murdered because he knew too
much or too little but he's the only one
I feel guilty about because it was all
my fault
if Fortescue had indeed given the trio
clues about the Elder ones he would have
been one of the single most important
leads in the Trio's quest to destroy
Voldemort 10. Helga hufflepuffs cauldron
Helga hufflepuff's Camp was a magical
item created by Hogwarts founder Helga
Hufflepuff herself it was a small golden
cup with two finely wrought handles
featuring a badger the emblem of
Hufflepuff house engraved on its side
adorned with several precious jewels in
the series the camp played a significant
role as one of the horcrux is created by
the Dark Lord Voldemort
after Voldemort stole the cup from near
strange vault in gringott's Wizarding
Bank it became one of the objects sought
after by Harry Hermione and Ron in their
quest to destroy the horcruxes in the
end it was destroyed by Hermione who
used a basilisk Fang but one interesting
tidbit about this horcrux was that it
was originally intended to be a cauldron
and not a camp cauldrons are quite
typical in folklore about witches and
wizards and reasonably prominent
throughout the Harry Potter books
capitalizing on this Rowling's original
thought was to make a hellgufflepuff's
horcrux a cauldron however Rowling later
decided that a cauldron was just too
clunky to Be an Effective horcrux I did
consider making a Helga hufflepuff's
hallow a cauldron but there was
something slightly comical and
incongruous about having such a large
and heavy cracks I wanted the
objects Harry had defined to be smaller
and more portable
and that concludes the list these
scrapped plot lines from the Harry
Potter story offer fascinating insights
into the creative process of JK Rowling
and the narrative decisions that shaped
the Beloved series and while some of
these plot lines seem intriguing we do
have to try and remember that they were
ultimately discarded in favor of a more
streamlined and cohesive storyline
which abandoned plot lines did you like
most do you ever need to add please
leave a comment down below and if you
enjoy the content please like the video
and subscribe to the channel until next
time remember it does not do to dwell on
dreams and forget to live
foreign